now kamala harris has gone a whopping 30
days without holding a press conference
since being tapped to handle
the biden-harris self-inflicted border
crisis
and it is a crisis and conditions on our
southern border are worsening by the
hour
and federal law enforcement now is
speaking out as a dhs
whistleblower spoke to our own sarah
carter and exposed
just how out of touch joe biden and
kamala harris really are
you saw him criticize the biden
administration last night here's a new
clip
what would be your worst fears
the worst fears is that we have
too many people to process
and not enough people to do our job
because what can happen well anything
can happen
but um it certainly just makes it right
for the bad players to have more success
and become stronger
but of course the mob the media they're
doing everything they can do
to help the democrats and downplay and
dismiss what is an
undeniable border disaster for example
politico following the associated press
is apparently forbidding reporters
from using the word crisis when writing
about
the crisis at the border here now with
reaction
joining us republican congressman devin
nunes along with former white house
senior adviser stephen miller
devin i'll start with you we see the
conditions texas is now
suing rightly the biden administration
because they're allowing all these kids
in biden's cages that are overflowing
and they're living on top of each other
with a high rate of positivity for covid
uh suing the that covert protocols that
they put on everybody else are
not even being practiced here
so sean i was actually just down there a
couple weeks ago i'm going to be out
there
here in about 10 days again on the
california border
and what's happening here it has nothing
to do
with anything but it's their own fault
this is very clearly what instead of
having to file for
asylum in your own country like the
trump administration was having him
do it's a free-for-all it's almost like
there's a deal
between the biden administration and the
drug cartels who are moving these people
uh this is why the border patrol and the
folks that work at the border patrol
it's why they want to be undercover
because they're doing very difficult
work out there having to
process all of these people and they're
completely overrun
when i was there there were not only
just the hundreds of kids that you see
that were without parents
this was in one day there were thousands
of others the day that i was there
3 500 people went over just in the
the small region that i was in on the
texas border you know
stephen if you look at what this
whistleblower
and by the way i thought we praised we
praised anonymous hearsay
non-whistleblower we we've applaud that
one
this guy's risking his career because of
the gag order that has been imposed on
border
patrol workers and officers
and you know here we have a situation at
the border that's unfolding now
as i look at this whole thing and what
this guy is saying is
the cartels the human traffickers the
drug traffickers and the gangs
they now have carp lunch while because
all the resources now
are dealing with this massive influx of
illegal immigrants
yes sean the cartels and the traffickers
use the families and minors that they
push across the border by the tens of
thousands
to create lanes and diversions to get
criminals drugs contraband and weapons
into the country
that is deliberate and planned and
purposeful and i talk to
agents i talk to homeland security
professionals at dhs
and they are terrified by the fact that
over 1
000 people a day are sneaking across
without
ever being apprehended that's in
addition to the people who are caught
and then released
these people are never even caught in
the first place and i will note
that my organization america first legal
has joined the state of texas
in suing the biden administration for
its illegal policy
of mass releasing covet-positive illegal
immigrants during a pandemic
and i will say one more thing kamala
harris's refusal
to address this issue is one of the
greatest derelictions of duty
that i have ever seen in my entire life
well yeah let me ask you because we're
watching this unfold
in real time this we have we're supposed
to be a nation of laws congressman you
are a lawmaker
they're ignoring the laws of the land
and they're you know your state is
aiding in a betting
by being a sanctuary state law breaking
joe biden is aiding in a betting law
breaking
how how come there's no check and
balance
and i don't know if i ate and embedded
you know somebody
jaywalking why would i end up in jail
well sean i think it's a key to what
stephen miller just said his
organization is actually trying to
get the judicial branch of government to
get involved so
as we know we've had this two-tiered
justice system on a
on a whole hosting range of issues but
this is another example
whenever the left brings something into
court it quickly gets solved whenever
republicans bring something into court
it takes forever and it goes slow so
that's why we have to have a legal
strategy to actually get
the courts to get involved it's the only
way
we're going to have to hope that we have
to hold biden and harris accountable
because until 2023 that's the soonest
that republicans could get
gavels back in the house and senate in
the meantime
we have to count on the judicial system
to enforce the laws
last words stephen we have 30 seconds
that's exactly right joe biden is
violating congressionally passed law
passed over a series of decades and
perhaps even more importantly
by refusing to uphold our laws joe biden
is violating the constitution
and his obligation to take care of the
laws be faithfully executed
and the courts can and should enjoin his
lawless conduct
and order him to enforce our borders
all right stephen miller hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else